bonsoir à toutes et à tous ici hargrove
j'espère que vous allez bien on se
retrouve pour une vidéo très spécial et
très attendu par vous la communauté car
nous allons parler de star wars 8 je
vous donnais mon avis que j'ai pensé du
film et il ya pas mal de choses à dire
alors je vais alors c'est une réaction à
chaud donc je vous demanderais d'être
indulgents je vais certainement dire
peut-être des conneries je vais
peut-être pas pensé à tout j'ai essayé
de prendre quelques petites notes à côté
mais
c'est pas sûr que je dise tout toute ma
pensée donc
voilà donc allons-y attaquons le morceau
parce qu'il ya vraiment des choses à
dire et je suis très impatient d'en
parler voilà ça fait deux ans déjà deux
ans
que je fais des vidéos théorie bon
c'était janvier 2016 les premières
vidéos théorie et j'ai compté il y en a
trente trois 33 théorie différentes sur
la nouvelle trilogie star wars et enfin
on a des réponses
enfin j'ai des réponses et je suis
tellement content d'avoir des réponses
et c'est là que je me dis que [ __ ] le
temps avance et enfin quoi donc on va en
parler aujourd'hui et je pense qu'on
fera un live débat un petit peu avec
ceux qui l'ont vu ce week-end pour en
parler
donc voilà je préfère vous prévenir bien
évidemment je vais spoil donc si vous
voulez pas exprès parce que vous ne
l'avez pas vu ça ne sert à rien de
regarder ses vidéos je peux pas parler
d'un film si je ne peux pas se poser en
fait y en a certes parlé du film en
question de résumer donc nous sommes
suite à star wars est du coup le premier
ordre a découvert la base des rebelles
et s'en va l'attaquer et du coup les
rebelles sont dans une très mauvaise
posture les le premier ordre faire un
assaut ils ont vraiment du mal à tenir
donc ça c'était pas étonnant c'était
logique ça j'en étais sûr à 100% que le
premier ordre dominerait serait
surpuissant parce que du coup le premier
ordre
le titre de star wars 8 était en rouge
donc déjà c'est signifier pas mal de
choses et la bande-annonce pareille ne
montrez pas mal de choses et dans la
logique des films on bat comme dans le
cas de 5,6 par exemple le cincle empire
contre attaque
bon bah là je m'étais dit bon bah le
premier rendre alors c'est pas un calque
c'est pas un calque du 5 mai c'est je me
doutais que le premier rendre serait
surpuissant donc voilà donc re r votre
rue retrouve luc et bien évidemment
l'udc est fermé comme une huître
fassaert est donc sage est pareil
j'étais évident donc luc a baissé les
bras
ça ne m'étonne pas du tout j'en était
quasiment sûr
et du coup barret va réussir quand même
à tirer les vers du nez à l'udc et à
apprendre la force
enfin à prendre entre guillemets la
force vite fait on va dire très vite
fait ce sera plutôt dans le neuf mais du
coup c'était évident aussi et voilà donc
ce que j'ai pensé de star wars 8 star
wars 8 et un star wars vraiment
différent je trouve des autres pas
vraiment mauvais je sais que beaucoup
ont été déçus par rapport à ça car star
wars 8 ne montrent pas vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup de spectacle on va dire s'il ya
peu de sabre laser genre de combat de
sabre laser il n'a pas vraiment
quasiment il y en a même pas du tout et
du coup ce star wars 8 est plus axé côté
humain on va dire en même temps ça ne
m'étonne pas non plus parce que nous
sommes dans une trilogie du coup et le
deuxième épisode c'est un petit peu de
transition faite le 1er mai les bases
tout ça le deuxième c'est un petit peu
de transition et le dernier bal à il y
aura vraiment du spectacle normalement
donc j'étais pas étonné et ce star wars
8 et particuliers et monde vraiment la
nouveauté au final
une nouveauté dans star wars wallace et
c'est pas comme d'habitude c'est pas il
ya les gentils les méchants les gentils
gagnent et cetera là il ya vraiment
c'était réellement très intéressant ce
point de vue du coup il était plus axé
côté humain par exemple je pense aux
péripéties avec finn et rose du coup
parce que du coup c'est deux personnages
là nous montre un côté humain ou
un côté humanité où il faut prendre
aussi soin des animaux tout ça qui sont
maltraités il ya aussi les esclaves et
nous montre aussi qu'au final le côté du
bien a aussi ses défauts en fait le côté
du bienfait aussi ses magouilles je
pense par exemple aux bombes qui sont
achetés
ad des trafiquants tous à des
trafiquants qui vendent des bombes tout
ça ils les vendent aux premiers rangs
mais au final ils les vendent aussi aux
rebelles donc comme quoi au final
les gentils c'est pas tant que ça le
bien et c'est justement ce que j'ai
vraiment apprécié surtout par rapport à
luc parce que l'udc est fermé mais ce
n'est pas pour une mauvaise raison c'est
que le cas pris conscience qu'au final
les jedi bas il fallait que ça se
termine et il l'a enfin compris les jedi
en fait doivent arrêter d'exister parce
que les jedi
si un jedi il y aura forcément un site
le côté bien engendre le côté obscur ici
elle la luminosité il ya de l'ombre si à
lombia de la luminosité
donc j'étais vraiment content de voir ça
cette évolution au final qu'au final on
prend conscience des erreurs qu'il ya eu
anakin était là-bas pour purifier on va
dire le monde comme élu il devait tuer
les sites mais aussi tuer les jedi au
final ce que les jedi ignorait car pour
eux les jedi c'était juste la
destruction des sites et hop tout allait
bien sauf que non le monde ne fonctionne
pas comme ça et ça ça m'a fait
réellement plaisir et
l'udc l'a très bien traduit ou
qu'ensuite bon ben on peut parler par
exemple des théories faire en fonction
de mes mes théories du coup bombe a
beaucoup sont fausses mais je regrette
rien je regrette rien du tout de toutes
les théories que j'ai partagé imaginer
trouver sur internet
car au final ça ça m'a permis de ça m'a
tellement hype et bah c'était la
recherche vous voulez la vérité tout ça
j'étais tellement content et je regrette
aucune théorie même si beaucoup sont
faussement 90% sont fausses mais ce
n'est pas grave
les théoriciens juste à imaginer on peut
penser par exemple du coup alors il ya
certaines j'avais raison par exemple le
lien avec des écailles lorraine j'étais
sûr qu'il y aurait une sorte de lien
entre les deux parce qu'au final rebbah
dans le film elle est au final une sorte
d'élu en finale elle est comme une élue
une élue qui est créé pour faire face à
kyle lowry ni snob
enfin surtout à kayes lorraine mais
c'est une élue pour faire face et jean
l'alter ego de kayes lorraine et du coup
basse ils ont une sorte de lien entre
eux on le voit avec la connectivité
qu'ils ont entre eux à communiquer entre
eux alors bien évidemment snop dit que
c'est lui qui crée cette connexion entre
les deux personnages mais au final bas
après bon bah on va en parler
ce n'est qu'après parce que ça c'est
l'objet vraiment celle c'est l'objet de
la vidéo limites mais bombasse nos
combats il se passe ce qui se passe
c'est que finalement ils ont quand même
le lien encore entre eux mêmes quand ce
n'est plus là donc il y a il ya cette
liaison entre les deux personnages il ya
cette liaison alors il ya aussi j'ai
beaucoup apprécié l'évolution de peau
d'iron peau d'un moine qui s'affirme de
plus en plus tout ça c'était vraiment
agréable
par contre fine c'est la petite
déception va dire bon baffin
n'était pas réellement utile je trouvais
au film les passages avec ce film j'ai
trouvé même limite un petit peu chiant
ce qu'au final
basta roi ça se passait à moitié en
trois temps comme bas dans chaque film
il y avait les passages où il y avait un
vrai avec lui qu il y avait les passages
avec les rebelles il y avait les
passages de la mission avec finn et rose
et ses passages à je les ai trouvé un
petit peu long longuet chiant fin
c'était un peu c'est un petit peu en
trop bon c'était pour montrer le côté
plus humain on va dire tout ça mais au
final ce qu'ils ont fait ça servait à
rien leur mission ne servait à rien
puisque au final il n'y avait pas besoin
de s'incruster dans
le vaisseau et je n'ai pas trouvé j'ai
pas trouvé si utile que safin
mais bon ça reste voilà mais c'était
très bien mais c'est vrai que les
passages à green était un petit peu bon
c'était pas non plus un croyant donc
bien évidemment pas plusieurs météorites
sont fausses tout ça donc j'ai je m'y
attendais à force parce que je me
souviens quand j'ai fait les théories
sur rai tout ça c'était suite à star
wars sets après plus le temps avance
qu'ils ont réfléchi j'ai grandi aussi
quand même en deux ans et
il est bande annonce tout ça donc au
final basse je me savais que certaines
théories étaient fausses mais on a enfin
des réponses
enfin des réponses rens rien n'est
vraiment confirmé pour certaines choses
mais on a des réponses bombe arrêts
c'est une fille de personnes donc beau
final j'avais raison sur ma dernière
vidéo théorie où je les ai créé serait
une sorte d'élu au final pour faire face
à kai lorraine puisque ça a l'air d'être
le cas
raila pour faire face à quai lors elle
représentait la dernière jedi qui doit
faire face à kai lorraine justement qui
est le symbole du côté obscur peut-être
l'élu du côté obscur donc ccd une fille
de deux ferrailleurs voilà elle c'est
c'est la fille de personnes donc le
personnage de calais lorraine aussi a
beaucoup évolué et je trouve ça bien
parce que dans cette île est vraiment je
sais pas comment dire pas l'adolescent
prépubères mais bon il est jeune tout ça
et quand ce nom que lui dit qu'il est
une merde tout ça limite bah oui il
était temps qu'ils prennent conscience
que c'était une merde tout ça alors j'ai
vraiment cru qu'il re basculerait du
côté lumineux mais justement bas avec la
petite intervention par exemple de yoda
par exemple alors ça ça fait plaisir la
petite intervention yoda donc ça bah
c'était s'était fortement possible que
l'un d'eux reviennent ça soit obi-wan
yoda ou ou encore une autre personne qui
est à l'immortalité en fait qui a
rejoint la force et au final basse et
c'était vraiment cool ce petit
intervention de yoda et du coup à yoda
nous confirme que baky lawrence est mort
c'est fini il est du côté obscur on peut
pas leur ramener bon après c'est pareil
on dit sami ben c'est pareil de dark
vador yoda donc personne pensé qu'on
pouvait sauver
anakin
de dark vador en fait et au final bas
l'udc a réussi l'impossible et dark
vador est revenu et a rebasculé du côté
lumineux donc en même temps je garde
espoir un petit peu pour calais lorraine
même si on nous dit clairement que non
c'est mort calais lorraine il est du
côté obscur et son personnage trop
évolué bien au final parce que du coup y
ait eu ce notre hit us n'augmente à en
parler juste après ils tuent snow qui au
final bailly devient de plus en plus
méchants entre guillemets il devient
vraiment le symbole du côté obscur et
son personnage commence à bien évoluer
je trouve alors que je vous cache pas
qu'au début du film j'étais inquiet
parce que du coup je me disais qu'est ce
qui va se passer bon bah les rebelles
sont dans une mauvaise posture mais il
va rien se passer de grandiose du coup
ils sont juste en mauvaise posture faut
qu'ils s'en sortent tout le film va se
baser là dessus mais au final ça aller
de surprise en surprise jusqu'à le
fameux événement ou snow kummer snoeck
est mort est ce que vous vous rendez
compte que snow qui est mort alors
justement ces jeux si je parlais de mon
inquiétude c'est justement j'en ai une
autre maintenant c'est que je me suis
dit mais qu'est ce qui va se passer dans
star wars 9 en fait j'avais l'impression
de voir le neuf en fait là à ce moment
là je me disais mais et smoke est mort
en fait voilà c'est terminé
qu'est-ce qui se passe et au final après
réflexion parce que du coup j'ai laissé
une journée passée histoire de bien
réfléchir tout ça bah il va se passer
des choses en neuf et comptez sur moi
pour vous faire des théories et parce
que l'âge déjà je vais aller le revoir
le film et il ya vraiment matière à dire
alors snoeck c'est vraiment le choc
c'était je pense la dernière la dernière
chose que je pensais qu'il puisse
arriver dans star wars 8 c'était que
snow kummer c'était vraiment la dernière
des choses que je pensais
voir dans le huit je lis j'imaginais pas
du tout et j'ai été choqué et du coup ça
mais pas mal de choses en question
notamment je parle est à l'heure de la
connectivité
alors il ya deux possibilités pour snow
d'après moi je vous les expliquer alors
déjà premièrement quand je vous parle la
connectivité thaler snow que disait que
c'était lui qui avait mis en connexion
caille lorraine et ray mais justement
snoeck quand il est mort après qu'elle
lorraine et ray ont de nouveau cette
connexion où il se revoit tous les deux
et communiquent vite fait ce qui
normalement était impossible du coup
puisque c'est nous qui les a mis en
connexion donc du coup déjà ça
interpelle et ensuite snoeck passe
clairement pas pour un pour un con il le
passe il passe clairement pour un comble
puisque pourtant il a l'air d'être très
fort c'est ça qui me perturbe c'est que
hitman irait comme une comme une
chaussette il s'en fout it l'apron et la
jettent leur amour à munich il s'en fout
complètement
il te dégage sky lorraine avec un petit
coup de foudre et puis voilà un petit
coup d'éclair de force et il s'est finie
et il se fait avoir par cas et lorraine
cai lorraine prend conscience au final
alors qu'elle rennes c'était le point
d'interrogation parce que ils
apprécieraient ça se voit il
apprécierait il envie d'être alliés
arrêt mais ils n'ont pas la même pas la
même vision alors on va en parler un
petit peu après on va en parler
maintenant directement s'écaille
lorraine en plus il a une vision plutôt
juste on va dire et c'est là que j'ai
fait j'ai aimé le personnage de camille
laurens et que cahill lorraine il va
ressembler à vador sauf qu'au final ce
nom que lui dit maintenant tu es une
merde t'es pas vador en fait t'es nul et
au final quel lorraine termine ce que
dark vador avait commencé il a une cause
plutôt justes techniquement parce qu'il
a la même à peu près que l'udc à peu
près il a compris aussi que les rebelles
tout ça faut que ça se termine ça dégage
le premier ordre ça dégage les sites ça
bon ça dégage mais vite fait un c'est ça
c'est ça le hic en fait dans son point
de vue et les jedi ça dégage
et justement il a raison sur ce point là
c'est qu'il faut tout dégage cependant
le problème c'est que cai lorraine
enfin on va l'appeler ben solo parce que
maintenant c'est plutôt ben solo finale
b en solo veut refaire le monde à son
image et c'est ça que j'ai trouvé
intéressant c'est qu'au final il a la
même cause que dark vador dark vador
anakin qui vous souvenez bien ils
voulaient détrôner palpatine et rebâtir
un monde à son image au début chose qui
n'a pas été fait
alors que kelly lorraine lui au final
l'a fait il a tué snoeck et il a pris sa
place pour rebâtir le monde à son image
et
devenir le leader en fait et c'est ça
que j'ai trouvé vraiment intéressant
parce qu'au final il prend vraiment le
rôle de dark vador final il réussit à
faire ce qui ce qu'ils voulaient bon
après il ya toujours ce côté un peu
jeune tout ça où il galère il a du mal
tout ça mais c'était vraiment
intéressant et c'est pour ça que j'ai
vraiment apprécié calais lorraine on se
rend compte qu'au final que eux que ce
n'est pas vraiment il est important sans
être important au final puisque c'est un
peu mon bail est là juste pour comment
désarmer mais c'est vraiment caille
lorraine qui dirige quoi une coupe en
revenir à snow knox et il ya deux points
de vue alors j'ai vraiment deux points
de vue et c'est vraiment là le gourou la
grosse question et c'est pour ça que je
valais le revoir au cinéma prochainement
la de ce week end je pense car c'est
vraiment le groupe en interrogation pour
moi donc du coup avec la connectivité du
coup quand ils meurent ils réussissent
quand même à se connecter à parler entre
eux snowdy que cai lorraine c'est
impossible que kay lorraine puisse
trahir ce noble puisque snow cli dans
ses pensées alors qu'au final batak
petits mouvements
shi sabre laser dans le bide c'est mort
il est coupé en deux snow qu'alerte se
vendre comme un bon commercial mais en
fait il ne l'est pas alors c'est ça qui
m'intrigue
donc en plus ce qui m'a choqué aussi
c'est par exemple sa tenue il n'a pas
vraiment une tenue de leader ou deux
le seigneur sith en fait il a une tenue
un petit peu il avait son truc jaune ça
fait un peu j'ai pas personnage qui aime
le luxe je sais pas comment dire mais au
final ce nokia passer un petit peu pour
un usurpateur au final ce qu'au final on
n'apprend rien de lui il était au
pouvoir
on sait juste qu'ils maîtrisent le côté
obscur mais il se fait avoir bêtement
par son apprenti et y meurent en fait
c'est aussi con que ça alors c'est ça
fait chier parce que du coup on ne sait
quasiment rien de snow qui est au final
on sait pas si on va en savoir plus
puisqu'il est mort donc ça va être
certainement que l'univers étendu on en
saura plus mais ce nom qui était
peut-être au final un usurpateur après
tout on ne sait rien hawks n'ont que ça
se trouve ça fait comme avec palpatine
palpatine bon ce n'était pas revenu sur
pattes heures mais il a pris le pouvoir
à part la politique sans utiliser la
force en fait
et sinon que c'est peut-être le septet
grâce à ça aussi un petit coup d'état il
a pris le pouvoir
grâce à des talents de politiciens
certainement et au final il a réussi à
amener le premier rang tout ça et puis a
gagné le coeur des gens enfin je sais
pas comment dire pas à gagner le coeur
des gens mais il a réussi à prendre le
pouvoir sans utiliser la force au final
il se vante de quelque chose qui n'est
pas donc ce serait certainement
peut-être un usurpateur
c'est une explication que je verrai
parce que snow qu'on le voyait quand
même grands on voit quand même sage
c'était l'image qu'on avait dans star
wars est et dans star wars 8
je vois tout l'inversant fait jouer un
personnage arrogant sûr de lui qui au
final meurt très bêtement et comme une
merde en fait sinon dans l'autre cas de
figure et c'est celui peut-être auquel
je pencherais peut-être le plus c'est
que kelly lorraine au final est très
très puissant et les surpuissants vague
on le voit dans le film il est
surpuissant il possède une énergie brute
comme dit luc tellement puissante que ça
ne l'effrayé lui même il voulait le tuer
et que du coup
échoué et du coup cas il aurait nos
finales est tellement puissant que snk
ne l'aurait même pas détecté au final il
serait un petit peu comme une sorte de
d'élus du côté obscur snoeck n'a même
pas détecté qu'il était
enfin il était tellement puissant que
snow tu n'as même pas détecté le fait
qu'ils tournent le sabre et qu'ils le
tuent comme une merde en fait et ce
serait une explication plus valides
techniquement parce que cai lorraine
possède de grands pouvoirs et ses
pouvoirs se sont encore accrues une
nouvelle fois donc voilà c'est des
questions comme ça c'était
assez impressionnant bond il ya eu des
petits moments chien dans le huit enfin
en tout cas ça me le 8 c'était vraiment
c'était vraiment un bon film après il y
aura encore beaucoup de mystères dans
neuf et franchement je me demande
comment ça va se terminer parce qu'il
faut savoir que y aura une nouvelle
trilogie star wars 10 11 12 mai avec des
nouveaux personnages normalement donc je
j'ai vraiment aucune idée pour le moment
et il ya vraiment encore beaucoup de
mystères ça se trouve ce n'est peut-être
même pas mort c'est ce que je me suis
dit wow à cedar space il est mort mais
il va revenir soit possible il peut
alors pas comme ça mais non c'est pas
d'expliquer sofina snow que c'est snow
qui il est mort il est mort comme une
[ __ ] et voilà quoi en tout cas ça a
beaucoup évolué et on voit vraiment la
relève
de star wars puisqu'au final l'udc est
parti donc luca rejoint la force
l'udc s'est laissé partir il va revenir
il a dit on se reverra de façon
immédiate et lorraine on se reverra il
va revenir mais en tant que fantôme
auprès de ré pour lui apprendre la force
comme yoda l'a convaincu et il reverra
certainement ben aussi dans le
pour pour le faire chier ou pour le
hanter comme il disait quoi ils vraiment
des petits clins d'oeil sympa tout ça
bombard r2 d2 avec obi wan kenobi en a
besoin de votre aide iota
l'eia au final maîtrise la force ça je
savais qu'elle avait des prédispositions
avec la force mais c'est ça faisait
plaisir de la voir au final utilisé un
petit peu la force
bon elle utilise pas non plus de ouf
mais c'est vraiment cadre danger en cas
de pour se sauver ou et ça ça fait
vraiment plaisir et c'était logique
puisque après tout elle est la fille de
l'élu elle est la fille de l'élu elle a
autant de pouvoir que l'udc est pareil
lui quand il est parti vont la petite
référence aux quatre avec le coucher de
soleil alors ça c'était vraiment un très
beau passage aussi
voilà je sais pas trop quoi dire de plus
bon bah les bandes annonces étaient
assez mensongère quand même parce que
bon bah les pentes annoncé dans cette
passe penser que ray maîtrisera côté
obscur et le côté lumineux peut-être
scellé bande-annonce spoil peuvent enfin
nous donnent des indices pour le neuf
je saurais pas dire en tout cas c'est un
très bon film
beaucoup de mystères je pense faire un
petit live débat avec vous et puis
compter sur moi pour faire des petits
théorie parce que là ça m'a vraiment
relancer je suis vraiment épais et
je suis impatient de voir la suite la
nouveauté que nous apportent star wars
bon après il ya quelques petits défauts
bien évidemment j'ai été très choqué par
exemple du côté humoristique du film est
vraiment beaucoup de moments marc enfin
comment dire star wars c'est pas
vraiment il ya des petits de passage ou
drôles comme ça vite fait mais là il y
avait vraiment des blagues
enfin on sent le côté disney quoi mais
en tout cas il ya des nouveautés qui
sont quand même sympa et au final on
voit que la force a beaucoup évolué et
puis la bei a pu d'enseignement ou autre
c'est là il reste plus créer calais
lorraine
deux jeunes un site gay die enfin un
adepte du côté obscur et jedi et c'est
à qui terminera l'autre et les deux
peuvent potentiellement disparaître au
final où les deux peuvent s'allier comme
on pensait donc c'est à voir mais trop
de mystères trop question faut que je
pense à ça que je réfléchisse mais si
vous vous fait chier vraiment lancée
chez ram en effet trop content là le
petit garçon qui ressurgit enfin bref
voilà je sais pas quoi dire de plus en
plus que je vous remercie d'avoir suivi
cette vidéo j'espère qu'elle vous aura
plu c'est une réaction à chaud donc
voilà j'essaye de enfin à chaud c'est
une réaction le lendemain mais bon c'est
quand même assez à chaud j'ai pensé
juste dans la journée à ce que je vais
dire vite fait pire que ça vous plaira
on va essayer de faire un petit avec
débat et puis des théories voilà cet
argot rock merci d'avoir suivi cette
vidéo n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
cliquez la vidéo on va parler star wars
achu trop content d'avoir vu 8 enfin des
réponses au bout de deux ans que le
liner soit avec vous allez ciao